janna Jackson steps out looking slim as
she heads to court with her estranged
husband the 51 year old singer and her
soon-to-be ex with some al mana reunited
at the Royal Courts of Justice on Friday
and I witnessed lzt Janet was in a great
mood
and was hugging and kissing her legal
team as she left the courthouse her
entourage was made up of seven people
including Janet's brother Randy et has
learned Jackson's estranged billionaire
huh be left alone shortly beforehand the
two reportedly didn't interact at all as
for Jackson's weight loss the eye
witness tells DT she looks great and
appears to be getting back in fighting
forms I just want to keep it root with
you guys earlier this month
a source close to the Jackson family
told ET the pop star had dropped 50
pound since welcoming her first child in
January the new mom has been training
dieting and eating clean before hitting
the road on her state of the world tour
this fall I'm continuing my tour as I
promised I'm so excited you guys so
excited
you